i want to just say you said adam that i
think is really important there were
loads of things what you said about
sleep as well patrick remind me to come
back to that but you said this thing
that's really important which is oh you
know the phone you use has the
technology that nasa were using like 30
years ago that feels like
democratization and in some ways is
but you've got to ask yourself what is
that technology being deployed for is it
being used to make your life better or
is it being used to invade your
attention now it could be used to make
your life better we could democratize it
at the moment it isn't so and this was
explained to me by some of the people
who designed these apps some of the
leading figures in silicon valley who've
subsequently kind of spoken out because
they're horrified by what they've done
so let's say you pick up your phone now
patrick and isn't it funny how it feels
quite invasive to touch someone's phone
sorry i don't mean to it feels like
weirdly personal like i've touched your
body
exactly exactly
don't mean to me now yeah yeah the um
the
the when you let's say you open your
facebook now or any of the major social
media apps
facebook or whichever one you choose
immediately starts to make money and it
makes money in two ways
the first way is obvious you start to
see ads we all know how that works the
second way is much more important
everything you do on facebook is scanned
and sorted by their algorithms because
they're building up a profile of who you
are so let's say that you like
donald trump
bette midler and you tell your mom you
just bought nappies okay so i don't
think anybody there's literally
categories it's gonna be like the
[ __ ] uh
clinton's like a castle but let's
imagine so it'll figure out okay you
like donald trump you're probably
conservative you like bette midler if
you're a man you're probably gay and
you're talking about diapers okay you've
got a baby it's building up an enorm
imagine it's got tens if not hundreds of
thousands of data points about you it's
learning all about you data data data in
order to be able to manipulate you
because you are not the customer of
facebook you're the product they sell to
advertisers so they can the reason why
they make the big bucks is they go to an
advertiser and they say we can target
someone so directly you're selling
diapers okay we can make sure your ads
don't go to me i don't have a baby we
can make sure the ads go only people you
want to target conservative gay people
with babies
we can get you there right that's how
that's why they're so lucrative but what
this means is
every time you close facebook or tiktok
or snapchat or any of them
what happens is those revenue streams
disappear so the business model of all
of the existing social media companies
is very simple
all of their engineering power all of
their algorithms all of this genius they
have is geared towards one thing
figuring out how do we get patrick and
adam and their kids to pick up their
phone more often and scroll for longer
right it is designed to invade our
attention sean parker one of the biggest
initial investors in facebook said yeah
the napster dude said um we designed
facebook specifically to invade people's
attention we knew what we were doing and
we did it anyway something new yeah well
it's a it's a much deeper form of
invasion so you think about a tv ad
let's say you placed an ad during the
johnny carson tonight right that's a
blanket thing that's going to whatever
it was back then 50 million people
that's very different to something that
knows what you messaged your mom about
last night that's learning all these
deep patterns about your mind yeah i
think the dm part the private
conversations that's your your
that's my privacy but it's not a privacy
that privacy is part of it but it's that
they can learn how to hack your
attention
much more accurately they're learning
the weaknesses
you think that's innovation or do you
think that's manipulation well it's a
form of innovation but it's a form of
innovation that harms our attention and
has all sorts of negative outcomes so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]